we're trying to create two separate
classes of World Records to recognize
that there's a natural world and there's
an enhanced world and we should
recognize that there are some world
records are objectively natural world
records and then there are some that are
enhanced world records and so the Tour
de France times that Lance Armstrong set
are definitely enhanced world records
and should be celebrated as the best of
humanity and science there's an honesty
to it which is undeniable but I think
you've already just used the word
natural and enhanced and
99.99 of the human population is natural
I don't think that's true at all
absolutely not we are Rife with
pharmacological enhancements not
generally performance enhancing well it
depends when you define performance
enhancing as to caffeine caffeine yes
azembic which is the most popular weight
loss drug in the United States now is
arguably a performance enhancement just
walk a Holland and Barrett according to
peer-reviewed scientific research 20 of
the goods in those stores would get you
banned under the water code